Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to Raft
Now you remember I said long long ago um let me think of it now
OH YEAH! "FUCK THE OCEAN!"
THE OCEAN CAN GO DIE!
I FUCKING HATE THE OCEAN!
THE OCEAN IS NOTHING BUT DEATH"
You remember that? You remember I said that?
You remember what i said?
YOU REMEMBER THAT?
ANYWAY,
You- an-
A-At you guys' suggestion
And at Bob's suggestion, as well,
Here is "Raft"
er-
Wade- uh- My friends-
My friends suggested this to me
That I play Raft
And euugh
It involves my ABSOLUTE worst phobia.
Like, my one 100% WORST PHOBIA
We're in the middle of the fucking ocean!
YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE AN ISLAND
You have to build your own island...
So, anyway..
That is not my construction
I just loaded this up for the first time-
MY NAME IS MARKIMOO-
MY NAME IS...
FUCK DA OH-SHEN
Oh, come on
Fuck dah OHSHIN-
ugh
My name is Mark hates...
Mark-
JUST MARK HATES
Just Mark hates this
'Cause Mark does hate-
I dunno what the story is...
There's probably a very- *sees game*
Woah
*softly* I dunno what the fuck...
I've never played this,
I've never seen this,
I've never looked up a tutorial about this-
Oh, god
What happens if you go in?
Oh, god no
Oh god
OOOH
GAWD NO
OH-
YOU CAN'T GO DOWN which is a nice thing
Oh my god
That reminds me,
I need to play Stranded Deep again
I dunno if there's been any updates about this game, but-
What the fuckin' fuck...?
Wh- OH
OOOOHHH
WHAAAT?
WHA-ha-ha-ha-haaat?
Whhhaat??
WHAT?
hooOHHHH NOOO
HI, FRIEND!
OOOH NO
Oh, that's not good
Oh, that's-
WHY IS HE THERE?
OH no...
Oh no
Okay, what do I do with this stuff that I've gotten??
OH NOOO
Okay...
So, I've got a-
I- I understand
I have to fish...
The STUFF
...Out of the ocean
To be able to survive
And- uhhh-
There's a shark
That wants to kill me
*Sniff*
OOOH GOD
Oh *cries*
*More cries*
Ok so there's gotta be like
a crafting menu right?
... That's how this stuff usually-
THERE we go ok.
So building hammer, axe
Chop down trees?
And the raft itself
Fishing rod, I need that I guess
But I can make a building hammer
OH
Instantaneous that is! Oh my god
Oh no, let me just get this stuff.
Hang on. Bloop, bloop
Reach, *half hearted singing* reach out and touch faaith
Reach out and touch death
Alright so, I need to stop being such a bitch.
Guys, you don't understand. Guys you don't-you don't understand.
Like you don't understand.
You may think it's a joke at this point, I fuckin' hate
I HATE with a PASSION the ocean.
I can't believe I caught that. Okay.
But I need to stop being a little baby
I need to just get into it.
I'm here
I gotta make the most of this, I just gotta do. I can't - I can't be pessimistic about it.
I gotta-I gotta make do. I'm just trying to get as much material as possible before I need to get goin' here. I'm really good at this hook
as I say immediately as I miss
FUCK YOU!
YOU MAKIN FUN OF ME OUT THERE?..... HUH?
BARRY?!??!
BARRY THE GREAT WHITE-
GREGORY? GREG WAYNE? Wayne Brady..
I'm gonna call you Wayne Brady
well fuck you didn't like that one
oh no.. I'M GONNA CALL YOU WAYNE BRADY
Alright so Wayne Brady's stalking me out in the ocean there
*quietly* heboooski
"Sorry about sisthy throw"
*bwink*
Shoop, nailed ya.
Or missed ya
Either-What is that?
I want that, whatever that is.
Let me just get these because I'm an opportunist. Okay, don't miss this
I didn't miss it. I was just planning
ShoooOOO BOINK
Hey! That was pretty good. Hey, that's pretty good. Okay.
So now that I've got that.
The crafting menu is tab? Yeah, tab.
Fishing rod, I don't have any rope
Oh boy, OH Boy. Chest? Cooking station? Water purifier?
Cropplot?
Tree cropplot
Item net?! I guess- I guess that's good but I still did-OH
You make rope with Ooh.
Uhahl
Okay, so that's good, that means that I can set this up
And be able to have that do that
So what I'm gonna do, is I'm gonna have a
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna get a
I'm gonna get a-ooh, where-where's Wayne Brady?
Where's Wayne Brady?
Alright, so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna start building more foundation.
'Cause I mean, heck yeah.
Ooh, alright, doodly do doodly doo do do do de de
AH AHA AH AH AH OH GOD
Okay, alright, oh God, oH God, oh man
That is amazingly scary.
That is astonishingly scary
TRIPLE
HEY WHAT THE FUCK?!
WHAT THE FUCK?! GET OFF MY FUCKING RAFT!!!
HOW DO-I-I CAN build a - fucking
Just fucking get- I can build a spear
How do I build it?
WHAT THE FUCK WAYNE BRADY YOU ASSHOLE
WHAT THE FUCK WHAT THE FUCK WAYNE BRADY
JESUS
WAYNE WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO SAY FOR YOURSELF? I've got a spear this time
I ain't GONNA FUCK AROUND WHEN IT COMES TO MY FUCKIN RAFT
Don't fuck on me I'll fuck on you right back
Don't fu
fucking Wayne
Wayne, I'm f-
I will not
HESITATE TO FUCK YOU UP
Okay, so my objective is eventually just to make one of everything because that's what I want to do
I should've made it more latitudially
*character starts coughing*
so that I could've crafted a codmore(?) anyway
Empty trash, empty tin can can be filled with salt water, that's nice.
Make more rope.
ugaaah, might as well grab the stuff that's floating right by
Fuckin' Wayne
Don't do it
What are you doing Wayne?
Oh WATER, I need water!
OH GOD I DIDN'T EVEN THINK ABOUT THAT HOW DO I GET WATER?
Water purifier! This! I need this!
Pure... put salt water
Put this right here, three, put that there.
Okay, uh uh it's good, it's good buddy
Okay, then eight, get some salt water, fill, fill, okay and how do I put it-?
How do I use you?
Uhh, three, cook! cook!
Okay, yay! Purify it FAAASTERR
FAASTER
This seems dangerous, I'm just gonna go ahead and say this
It seems really dangerous to just have this on a fuckin' boat
in the middle of the ocean. I mean I know I'm desperate and all that but
I should probably not do that. Is this ready yet?
"Pick up drinkable water"
Put more in there
Alright, eight. Drink!
*swallowing noise*
YAAAY I did it!
uhuhuh I don't know
Alright, fuckin' Wayne Brady , don't fuckin-don't fuck on me, don't fuck on me,  don't sneak on me
Ah uh he's gonna SNEAK ON ME
Okay, heh,
Barrel Barrel! thank you.
Okay, got stuff and things and thatch
Don't even-I'll fuck you up. I will fuck you up boy I will fuck you up
Okay, I got-I got a potato so I
I can cook something, I think. Yeah, I can. I can definitely do that. Ok. Just put that in
Put that in... there
Okay, four. Okay, that's good
That's good. That's good thus far.
I've got a potato so I can cook that.
"Pick up drinkable water"
Let's see, drink that.
Okay
Fill that, cook that,
Alright, more, yes, yes, yes.
No, didn't get that
A du du duuuuuu
Ah fuck
*woosh of hook being thrown*
I fucked up
I fucked-I didn't need to throw at all
It's really just like a hobby of mine
to throw things into the ocean at random.
You know, I know it's not important but you know
I just feel like it's good exercise for me and Wayne Brady out here.
Did I fucking get that potato? I did, it's right here.
Okay.
*crunching of potato as it's being eaten*
That was a good potato! I think.
Alright. Good thing there's just a never ending stream of supplies but
uhlugh olughl
Sorry
The demons tried to get out of my body
This is, oddly enough, a really interesting system of doing it.
Like you have an ever present threat.
It really simplifies the survival experience in a really interesting way
NOT IN A GOOD WAY THAT I LIKE, but you know in an interesting one.
Doodly do,
I already have ten cans, I don't need more of those.
Ooh perfect!
Glug glug, okay!
Glug, glug. I seem to have a good system here. I'd like to another one of these and I'm gonna do that.
But now I'm gonna get another one of these.
Gonna put that right... I'm gonna get like a station going.
Boink okay
Then put you in there, cook you up, cook you up
cook you-do you think you can GET AWAY FROM ME!?
DO YOU THINK YOU CAN GET AWAY FROM THE MARKIPLIER??
NO, I HATE THE OCEAN and so should you
Ok, get you, get you, get you, yes.
Oh, don't even think about it!
I'LL FUCK YOU UP, I'LL FUCK YOU UP, I'LL FUCK YOU UP,  I WILL FU-
YEAH WAYNE BRADY HA YEAH GET THE FUCK OUT OF HERE WAYNE
*quietly* I'll fuck you up
There better not be more of you as time goes on
I have a funny feeling there's gonna be more of you as time goes on.
Ok, drinkable water, yeah, that's what I like to see.
Ok, so put that in three. Drug-glug glug okay.
Then put this over here
Fill, fill
God damn it, there's so much shit.
Okay, I'm just gonna put the scrap, the wood and the wood. Spear over here. This here.
Cook these up, boink, boink.
Cook my potato, cook that up, that's good.
I don't know where I'm getting all these potatoes from but-oh the BARRELS. Ahh
Wayne Brady, don't kill me, don't kill me, don't uuh
I know they're coming right for me but I just FEEL LIKE IT
ERRUGGHHAA
So now that I'm not panicking, let's actually take a look at this.
Cropplot, I should have a cropplot to try to make some sort of potato farm.
Like that would make the most sense to me.
So let me put this...
Try to maximize space here. It doesn't look good
Ah, I guess I shouldn't do that because eventually I'm just gonna build out so.
Put that there. Let me try to plant a potato. Okay.
Alright.
Okay. Uhh drink, drink, fill, fill, cook, cook
Okay. OOH double barrel
Oh fuck. It's like a double barrel shotgun of love.
Yes, thank you.
Thank you.
hi-YAAAAA
Nailed it
Fuckin' got the scrap too
Okay, that's good. I got a palm seed.
Well, that's interesting, I don't know how I'm gonna be able to get a palm seed out of that but.. okay.
Oh fuck you Wayne Brady
So what I need-OH tree cropplot. Okay that's good
A chest, tree cropplot, a fishing pole! That'd be good.
That's what I need, I need one of those!
Get the rope going, more rope, I'm doing great!
Is there anything else I could build?
OH OOOH THAT'S AWESOME
Oh that's aweseome
Okay, so, woahoh
It doesn't make a lot of sense in terms of selecting, oh my god.
Okay, you know what? I'm just gonna make  some more pillars out this way. Okay.
So now that I'm wider, which is probably what I needed in the first place.
Don't- Wayne, Wayne, woah
I thought I saw the tail of something big in the distance and I did not like what I saw.
Oh boy.
Okay, so, I dunno how-oh harvest! Two potatoes!? Okay! Plant one.
Cook one
Plant.
Plant. Wait, how many potatoes did I have? Probably a lot apparently.
Okay
Soo, eee, stop it
Stop it
Okay, more potatoes! That's good. I can just put this in here.
Oh, it's full. Oh, well I guess I can cook it then.
I've got drinkable water.
That's nice.
Okay, so I thi-I think I've got generally a system going on here.
And it's not too bad. Like I gotta admit.
This is going pretty smoothly.
I mean, so long as there aren't more sharks appearing.
I gotta get the whole cast of
Whose Line Is It Anyway? up in my grill. So long as that doesn't happen I sh-I should be generally okay.
Oh Wayne Brady's B-lining. OAH that's terrifying.
DON'T DO IT WAYNE
WAYNE
WAYNE THINK ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE DOING
Okay, alright, that's good.
You thought about that. NO WAYNE NO I SEE WHAT YOU'RE DOING NO
WAYNE
NOO
NO NO MEANS NO STRANGER DANGER
Do I need to repair that or somethin'?
Oh shit.
Woaah
That's COOL
OH I WANT THAT
I don't know what I'm gonna do with that but I want it. I wanna build other floors.
Oh shit.
Is that Wayne? or is that someone else?
That better not-Okay, I'm gonna try to fiish. Huuhhh
I love fishing
Fishing's cool
I don't know when...
dop
HEY, I got a fish, I got a raw Mackerel, woah
Hey, don't look at me li-oh shit
Don't look at me like that
OOH
You went on there real quick. Okay
Well, I mean, I'm doing oddly good for myself. Maybe I could just use this as like a platform
to dive head first into the mouth of the fucking shark
Okay, got these. dooby de doop boop boop boop
Man I'm gonna need more cookers.
That's what I'm gonna need. I need-I need to put them in a better place anyway.
I could put them under here, that might be nice.
No, not that.
Seven.
Boop, there we go, good. Eight.
AW I can't put another!
AW that's stupid
I could fit it right here though.
*mocking voice* "'R' to rotate"
Right there. That'll be good. That's good.
Then I put my potatoes there. Woah shit, missing a lot of shit.
Doodly doo
Okay
Hol-woaah mackerel
Contains a lot of protein
HELL yeah
Okay, so I'm gonna eat this up.
Oh shit, that's nice
Plant these seeds
Oh, shit, come back here!
Come back, come back. Ooooh, don't come back
There's been a lot less supplies than I was hoping there'd be.
And they seem to all be drifting over that way now. So maybe I built too far over in one direction and it's kinda limiting the flow
But then again, that could be a good thing.
'Cause there was-there was another material I could have built.
Like um
There's this net thing
Use to catch items floating by
So how does this work?
OOOOHH
Oh, that's really cool.
Okay
So then you can just walk over here
I could build out completely this way
And then I would catch everything that I need
But I don't have enough already. I need more...
I need to make more rope
Okay, I've got a lot more nets now. So I'm gonna boop that
I'm gonna boop this
Boop. That's a nice boop.
Ah man,  that's a-that's a sweet boop!
Ah, that's a nice net!
Alright, now Wayne, do not fuck up my Goddamn net.
I swear
Also, I swear that as soon as I put those nets over there, it started putting all the other things on the wrong side.
ITS NOT MY FAULT
They just did it that way
Alright so I need the drinkable water. I need to put the rope away, I need to grab the thatch.
I need to grab all the goodies, the scrap. I don't understand how the metals floating but I'm not gonna question reality when I'm desperate.
Need to drink the water, need to put the-fill the cans, need to put 'em cookin
OH, AH MY NET
YES
YES MY SWEET NET
HELL YEAH
Awesome
That works great. That works wonderfully.
Look at this sweet catch bruh
Okay
So now that I'm doing relatively alright,
I-I want to get more nets out there but I'm just gonna hold off for now
I'm going to build
Eeeh nah, I'm gonna hold off. So now that I've got enough supplies, I think I'm gonna start building
Aw jeez
Wayne's being a bit of a bitch
But that's okay, I'll forgive him
Okay, so I'm gonna build
I'm gonna build up, I'm gonna build up. I don't need-well I guess I do need more foundation over here but
I'm gonna kinda build like a-
Oh, HEY DID THAT BOTHER YOU WAYNE?
HUH?
NNO
NO
STOP
Jesus Christ, that asshole!
Alright, so now that I got what I needed I'm gonna build a second floor because I'm very ambitious like that.
So I want to build...
I guess I'll need a pillar
Kind of a...
pillar right? I'll need a pillar. Yeah? I think so. Yeah
I'm pretty sure.
Then I need a floor.
Ooh uh huh hahaha
Well that's interesting but
I don't know what the benefit of having this is.
Alright, this IS MY PERCH
IT'S MY LONELINESS PERCH
ITS WHERE I GO TO SHOUT HOW LONELY I AM AT TIMES
JUST HAD TO STOP AND GET THIS STUFF BEFORE I DECLARE MY LONELINESS TO THE WORLD
ALRIGHT, EVERYBODY READY?
AH THAT'S A GOOD HORIZON TO LOOK UPON
I'M LONELY
I HAVE NO FRIIEENDS
I HAVE NO WIIIIFE
MY KIDS ARE DEAAAAD
Was that good? Good amount of loneliness?
Hey WAYNE BRADY
ALL MY FRIENDS THAT I HAD HAAATE ME
I GOT FIRED FROM MY JOOOB
I'VE NEVER PUT MONEY IN MY PENSION PLAAN
I HATE SHAAARKS
Okay, alright, thanks-thanks Wayne.
Thanks for listening to my loneliness, I'm glad that I got assembled items while I was being incredibly lonely.
Just, you know, it's a good change of pace.
Alright, so, what else can I make?
What else can I make?
A tree cropplot.
I could put that up on my loneliness perch.
Well that do-
That does not fit on my loneliness perch.
Well, this seems ah-
this seems
this seems too big
But oh well, you know what?
Markiplier's not efficient, that's for damn sure.
If it fits, I like it.
Alright, so I'm gonna build a palm tree apparently.
OKAY
Just gonna wait a couple hours for that to finish up.
Gonna drink my drinkable water in the meantime.
Gonna go have some drinkable water
Good water, drinkable.
It's good, drinkable and stuff. Anyway, back up on my loneliness perch.
Let's see. Ahhh what-what direction have I not declared my loneliness? I don't think I've done it this way yet. Hmm
Okay. Alright then.
I'M INCABABLE OF FEELING LOOOVE
I DON'T EVEN HAVE A BEAC-
What the FUCK-
WAYNE
What the fuck was that?
Ooh, I didn't like that.
I DON'T EVEN HAVE A BEACH BALL TO BE MY FRIIEEND
I don't even have Tiny Box Tim to be my friend...
Oh thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
OOH It's tiny. I don't think that's how those things grow.
I also don't think that I could see them grow right before my eyes.
Well that's bizarre. That is just
the weirdest
I don't know where I got all this dirt from
But who am I to complain about free dirt?
Okay
Build more, let's build more of these bad boys over here.
Yeah, what do you think of that Wayne?!
HUH?
Right. fuckin' asshole.
Maybe if I build some walls it might funnel my loneliness.
OOH
Where did get the cloth?
I dunno, whatever.
Can I build another one?
Can I build one more of those bad boys up here?
Please?
Pretty please?
Fine.
HEEEY FUCKING WAYNE
FUCKING WAYNE, GOD DAMN IT WAYNE-Oh
Oh
Oh!
OOH
OHOHOHHHOH
I kil-oh shit
I killed Wayne
I don't think I was supposed to kill Wayne.
Oh I don't-I don't think anything likes me killing Wayne..
Ooh
Something tells me that might've been a bad idea
Oh, I shouldn't have killed Wayne.
Oh no!
Now that I think about it Wayne might've been my only friend in this horrible
survival circumstance. My only friend is trying to kill me.
How appropriate.
Oh well, whatever.
Get me out of this fuckin-fucking fuck
Okay, alright then. SO, anyway, I think that's about the long and the short of the game. I don't know what the end goal is just other than survival.
There's not much else to do.
I'm gonna-I'm gonna taunt this guy.
You know what? I'm so lonely
maybe I'm just gonna hug it out with a bro
Uh ohh
ooohhhaho
hey
ueh
*character grunting in pain*
*very quietly laughing*
*laughter*
What an anti-climatic end
Oh well, anyway. so that was Raft
This game is available on Itch.io
And it's not bad. There's some potential here. It's a bit too simplified though.
I think it needs more elements to it but I like the concept. The concept is interesting.
So long as you can make the threats kind of incrementally get better.
I think like there needs to be a weather system.
There needs to be like crisis's. There need to be like
you know, other stuff. More dangerous. More sharks and all that stuff. but either way
It's pretty cool
So thank you everybody so much for watching. Let me know what you thought of it down in the comments below.
And as always, I will see you in the next video!
BUH-BYE
*outro music*